[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
how does the revision of iso 8655 affect
the quality control of my pipettes
i am kaylee bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrutz and brought to you
by sartorius
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit sartorius.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
yoni oka
product manager at sartorius
and axel tope
product manager services at sartorius
yoni axel you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction
now let's jump right into the topic
today we are talking about iso 8655
a brand new revision of the private
standard
topics for today we have a general what
is the iso 8655 series
and we're going to talk about pipettes
and finally we're going to talk about
test testing and calibrating pipettes
and also balances and how the
requirements have changed with the new
revision
so what is the iso 8655 series
this series
is called piston operated volumetric
apparatus or pogba you might see or hear
the shortened version today as well
in practical terms it means all kinds of
different devices
that you use to transfer liquids like
pipettes
threads
repeaters etc but for simply the sake uh
we are gonna refer to pogba or then in
most of the cases just pipet we are
focusing here on micropipettes
this standard series it addresses the
needs
of manufacturers
and calibration laboratories all test
houses
but also it gives a very good basis for
users
on
how to use the devices and how to take
care of the devices
for manufacturers
it gives you
instructions or guidelines and and rules
for basis of quality control
um
how to declare conf con declarations of
conformity
and
also more general instructions for
example product markings and user
guidance we're going to touch both of
those a little bit later
and for calibration laboratories or test
houses
gives you instructions how to test
private
it gives you instruction what you need
to account what kind of environment you
need to be in
and what kind of procedure you need to
follow to test the private
but then to what's the end user the
person who's actually going to use the
pipette what's in it for me
well if a manufacturer
says and claims that they follow the
standard it's gonna help you with the
procurement
because you know that the
products you are about to purchase are
made with a certain level of quality or
unfollowed certain processes
and then it gives you the basis and
guidance
how to
monitor the products when they are in
use so in practical terms when to
calibrate what sort of a protocol to
follow
for calibration
etc
but just to be extra clear it doesn't
give you exact
rules to follow so it gives you a basis
of what you can do but it's always the
responsibility for the end user the
private owner to decide what kind of
protocol to follow and when to calibrate
the privates
the series consists of nine different
parts
first part is the general terminology
general requirements and use
recommendations
second part is for pipettes
this is definitely what we're gonna
focus on here today we have a separate
section for pipettes only
parts through three to five are breads
dilators and dispensers
and then part six to eight
are different testing methods
we have two reference methods part six
and eight and then in part seven we have
alternative methods
as well but all those part testing
methods we're going to go through
quite needed in a later section as well
then part nine is manually operated
laboratory syringes
so we have five parts for different kind
of liquid transfer devices
all of those are piston operated as the
name suggests and then three parts for
testing such devices
i said this is a brand new revision to
the standard so what's the timeline
uh
it was already released so 2022 revision
revision number two was already
released by the iso committee
but the timeline when it becomes valid
in your area or your country might vary
different countries even within the eu
take this in use in different times so
for example in france we know that the
translation is already done and it's
been taken into use but for example
germany and finland it's still being
prepared
i would assume that within the next six
months most countries have taken the new
revision in use but then again have to
highlight that you need to follow the
local authorities to see what's the
status
okay that was the general introduction
what is the standard series now let's
take a look at the pipettes so part two
a little bit closer
in part two
the standard
defines and specifies meteorological
requirements of maximum permissible
errors for the pipettes
requirements for markings
and what kind of information a
manufacturer must provide for
users um maximum permissible errors
that's quite clear you have a systematic
error and random error and maximum
limits that the devices must be able to
fulfill
what i want to highlight here is that
it's always a private and deep
combination that such limits are given
to
then requirement for markings so
here in the picture you see that there's
a manufacturer name there's brand name
and there's a volume so those are just a
couple of examples what you need to have
in in private set they need to be
permanent
and then information to be provided for
users
when you bring new private market you
need to have a certain set of
information like how to use it how to
clean it how to decontaminate so how to
take care of it as well as a
recommendation
for calibration
this part 2
includes
air displacement and positive
displacement pipettes
multi-channel and single channel variant
and it always combines the tips and the
pro
instrument together
so this is a very important highlight
let's go into the tips so what actually
changed between the first revision and
the second revision
is that in second revision the language
concerning tips is much more strict
in standard it says that the deep
manufacturers shall prove that the
system including the dip fulfills the
requirement
for maximum permissible errors
and this must include variation in
manufacturing as well
what does it mean in practical terms so
at the moment uh previously in the
market
you had a lot of specifications but they
were usually marked for pipettes
so let's say a tux pipette for example
can have a maximum
systematic error and maximum random
error
with the new revision of the standard
you have to separate
different tips so if you claim that you
can use multiple different types of tips
for example a standard tip and a filter
tip
or a filter tip and a extender tip for
example
the manufacturer of the tip must be able
to prove that the system with that
particular tip and that particular
pipette is going to work
then what else they changed when it
comes to tips
it's much clearer now that tips are
signal use
meaning you can mount the tips once
but obviously you can use the mounted
tip for several replicates so you can
use it it multiple times
when it's in a private but when you
mount it and you check it then it's done
the tips shall not be clean for reuse
and then
for multichannel pipettes specifically
there is no limit for under 100
microliter volume private tips how much
they can vary in the nominal space
and in more practical this means how
bend the tips can be
there is already there was already in
the first revision limits for
other types of tips but now especially
for the smaller volume there are more
strict
rules in in place and i do believe the
reasoning is clear because we are moving
more towards smaller micro well plates
so the tips especially the small tips
they need to be very straight so you
don't face any problems when hitting the
walls
in the maximum permissible errors
uh even the first revision had some much
more permissible errors but in the
second revision they made it easier for
the end user this is my my view on that
in the first edition they only gave you
error limits for the nominal volume of
the pivot let's take a case example 100
microliter volume pipet
they would only give you a limit for 100
microliters and then you need yourself
to calculate based on the microliter
value you needed to calculate the
percentage maximum error for the
attested volume so if you use the 100
microgrid of bibet in 50 microliters you
needed to use the same
microliter maximal permissible errors
and calculate the percentage based on
that
now the new revision gives you the
limits for 100 so the nominal volume 50
and the 10 000 as well
multichannel pivots they used to be
twice the limit for single channel pipet
but now there is a new table just for
multichannel buybacks
and
that's a welcomed edition as well so
multicenter websites have their own
table now
the limits are different compared to
single channel privates
but they are not twice the amount what
they used to be which is good for the
user
and this is extremely important these
limits apply to the total system of
pipette and tip
so you can't calibrate a pipette without
a tip and the tip must be specific to
the calibration and what we are going to
use
so let's say you have a two total
different tip types and you switch from
one to another
then you need to recalibrate the pivot
with the new div type
then one big addition as well was the
inclusion of electronic bipaps
so electronic pipettes
they are now included in one of the
annexes to the standard
which is very good because now the
standard recognizes that there are
multiple
different pipetting modes so how you can
use the pivot
previously the standard only recognized
forward pipetting as a like standard
method of testing the privates which is
still the case but there was no mention
of an electronic private and the
capabilities that the electronic
privates offer
a couple of highlights here
speed setting for the electronic private
can affect the results you get
thus
the speed setting must be visible in the
calibration certificate
so when you see a calibration
certificate and you see that this pivot
was tested in 150 and 10 microliters you
should also see the speed setting that
it was used with
and then maybe the most important thing
is that now there is a method for
testing the multi-dispensing mode
this is something that some
manufacturers have already done before
but there was no standardized way of
doing it so it was
challenging to compare
the performance of an electronic pipette
if you check the manufacturer's data but
now there is a standardized way to doing
it and comparing different bundles
should be a bit easier which is really
good for the user
and then user information a
small collection of different factors
that the manufacturer must provide
usable volume rate this is something you
need to always have marked in the
pipette so minimum and maximum volume in
case of adjustable pipette or if it's a
fixed volume pipet then obviously it's
going to be just a fixed value
basis of adjustment so in which
temperature the pilot was adjusted to
and then maximum permissible error
limits
and those can differ from the iso
standard they can't be worse but they
can be better
list of tips that can be used with the
pipette
um there is no established way in a
market to do this as of yet but i would
assume that there is going to be a list
of the same manufacture tips
and
then suggestion for the basis of routine
testing
again i want to highlight this is just a
manufacturer's recommendation
this does not tie in the user so user in
the end is still responsible of creating
the testing
procedure how often the test and how the
test etc
and information on care cleaning
sterilization
and upon request the chemical
compatibility
then tip manufacturer what information
the tip manufacturer must provide
her tip
model
notif type
manufacturer must provide an information
which manufacturer and which model of
pipette the dips can be used with
this is something that the standard
theories didn't touch earlier but this
is a brand new addition
and chemical compatibility and
stabilization data in case they ask the
royal tips
and the nominal volume
and here you see the difference the
pipettes they can have volume range but
tips usually have a nominal volume only
okay that was about the tips and now i'd
like to hand over to axel for test and
calibration
yeah thank you yoni
and welcome also from my site
in the next part we like now to focus on
test and calibration of piston-operated
volumetric apparatus
means we will have a deeper look to part
6 part 7 and part 8 of the new iso
as it is uncomfortable to say always
piston-operated volumetric aberrators i
will say in the next slides only
pipettes
whereby also all the other provas
dispensers burettes and dilutors are
also meant
but
let's start with some basics
what does calibration mean
and
why is calibration of a pipette
necessary at all
so each pipette
and this is independent if it's a
mechanical or an electronic pipet
and of course also independent from the
pipette manufacturer and the pipette
model has a small error
means if you select for example a volume
of 300 microliter
you will never get exactly this 300
microliter dispensed
it can be a very small deviation
but there will always be
a small error
during the calibration
a comparison
of the selected volume
in our example the 300 microliter
with a known or correct volume is done
as a result of the calibration
you will see the systematic
and random deviation of the pipet
in the
new iso 8655 there are now three
different procedures described on how to
perform such a pipette calibration
in part 6 and 8
reference measurement procedures are
described
and
in part 7
an alternative procedure is described
but
why to calibrate pipette at all
calibration
is the basis for reliable and
reproducible pipetting results
and calibration confirms that a pipette
works inside its small error limits
one of the
main new points in the new iso is that
there are now two
instead of for one different reference
measurement procedures included
so in the former iso
only the gravimetric measurement
procedure had been described
this gravimetric measurement procedure
is now losing its unique position
part 6
of the new iso describes the gravimetric
reference measurement procedure
and part 8
of the new iso
describes now the new photometric
reference measurement procedure
the for the metric procedure
is given an equal status
as a second reference procedure
this means
the new iso does not give any
recommendation
when to use which procedure
it also does not say
if one procedure works better
for the one or the other device so the
new iso does not favor it the one or the
other procedure
next to these two reference procedures
in part 6 and part 8
alternative procedures
are described in part 7 of the new iso
to follow one of the reference
procedures
it is necessary to perform the
calibration
inside very strict environmental
conditions
deviations from these strict
requirements are not permanent permitted
when following part six or part eight
and calibrating a pipette for example in
a normal calibration lab or in the
normal app
on the customer side it will often be
not possible to fulfill
all these strict requirements that are
necessary if you calibrate according to
a reference measurement procedure
and therefore the new iso describes in
part 7
alternative measurement procedures
these alternative procedures
allow deviations
from the strict environmental
requirements
within defined limits
so alternative gravimetric measurements
can be performed according to part 7
of the new iso or
part 7 a2 of the new iso
let's go on now with an important
question
that may come up with reference and
alternative measurement procedures
so can a metrological confirmation be
given under an alternative procedure
and the clear answer here is yes a
metrologic confirmation can be given
but there are two requirements that need
to be fulfilled
first
at least 10 measurements
must be performed per selected volume
and second the measurement procedure
must be validated by comparison to a
reference procedure
if both requirements are fulfilled a
metrological confirmation
can be then also given under part 7
of the new iso
and a second
important question
the new iso distinguish between
calibration and test
what are the differences
so metrological confirmation can be
given by both
calibration and tests
the only difference is
that the measurement uncertainty
must be given on a calibration
certificate
while
this is optional
when doing a test
so on a test report the measurement
uncertainty is not required while this
is a must on a calibration certificate
as already said
the environmental conditions under part
6 and 8 are very strict
the reason behind is that variations in
the environmental conditions
has an influence on the test
and calibration results
the table
shows general effects on
environmental changes
with distilled water and how this
affects the dispensed volume
so looking
first at the air temperature
when the air temperature increases
the air space between the seal and the
liquid
as well as mechanical parts expand a
little bit
as a consequence
the pipetted volume will be a little bit
less
air humidity
when the humidity increases
the air space
is more moist
thus
less evaporation from the liquid will
happen
and as a consequence here the dispensed
volume
goes a little bit up
looking to the air pressure
increases in the air pressure
compresses the air space
and the dispensed volume here will go a
little bit up
and last but not least
the
liquid temperature
liquids
that are colder than the air
will cool down the pipettes and the
airspace temporarily
and this effects
that the pipetted volume
goes a little bit down
the number of test points and
measurements per test points
are very critical
as they have a direct effect on the
quality of the calibration and test
results
for a variable volume pipet
at least 10 measurements
at at least three volumes are required
if performing a test or a calibration
under part 6 part 7 or part 8 of the new
iso
this require or this measurement type
we call
a 10.3 calibration means
10 repetitions
at three volumes
other
other measurement types than the 10.3
calibration
with less measurement points and
less measurements per test point
are only possible
when performing test or calibration
under part 7 a2 of the new iso here is
it is for example possible to perform a
5.3 calibration
which would mean that you do only five
measurements at three volumes
or a
10.2 calibration which would mean
10 measurements at two volumes
but let's have now a
bit deeper look
on the different parts of the new iso
and their requirements
so
when
first of all looking to the part six of
the iso
the following environmental
conditions need to be fulfilled here
the test room temperature
must be between 17 and 23 degrees
the test temperature variation
from
beginning of the test to the end of the
test
should not be more than zero 0.5 degrees
and this is the same for the water
temperature
the water temperature shall not deviate
more than 0.5 degrees
from the air temperature
so if for example the air temperature is
21.5 degrees the water temperature must
be between
21 and 22 degrees
test room humidity
here we do have a much stricter
requirement than in the old iso
the test room humidity must be between
45 and 80 percent of relative humidity
and
last but not least here the air pressure
for the air pressure
no
specifications are given
just need to be recorded during the
calibration
the test conditions
a calibration under part six requires at
least
three calibration points
and the three calibration points must be
at nominal volume of the pipet
at fifty percent of nominal volume
and at ten percent of nominal volume
as pointed out earlier at least 10
measurements
per volume are required here
and last but not least tip change and
this is something quite new in the new
iso
the new iso requires at least
one tip change
per measured volume
if we compare the requirements of part 6
to the requirements under part 7
we see the following differences that
are highlighted here
the test room and water temperature
as well as the humidity now just need to
be recorded during the calibration
but there are no limits given
same as under part 6
the temperature shall not vary more than
0.5 degrees from beginning
to the end of the test
the requirements on
test points tested volumes and
measurements per test point
are exactly the same as on the pulse 6.
when
performing a test or calibration under
part 7 a2
it is also possible to reduce the
calibration points
and to change the tested volumes
which mean that the calibration must not
be performed anymore at nominal volume
50 and 10 percent of nominal volume
here you are free
to choose the volume where you want to
have the pipet calibrated
here
it is also possible to change the number
of measurements per test point
means less than 10 replicate
measurements per pest points are
possible here
so
working under
part 7 a2
gives the user really the freedom
to adapt the test conditions to his
specific needs
the only requirement that is given here
is
that
all deviations
that
or all points that deviate from the
requirements under part six
must be recorded and reported
so you
just need to document the changes from
part six but all the other things are
more or less free
but let's go on with two more frequently
asked questions
why
part six and 7 of the new iso require a
tip change during the calibration
as explained earlier by yoni
the new iso describes the pipette and
the tip as one system which means that
the exchangeable parts
are now seen as an integral part of the
whole pipet
and therefore
calibration results are only valid for
the tip type used during the calibration
so in case the pipette is used with
different tip types
a separate calibration
should be performed with each tip type
and in order to detect variations in the
dispensing
that result from the tip
and the tip quality
at least two tips
must be used
for calibrated volume so you need to
change the tip once
means
if you do for example here at 10.3
calibration
in total six tips are needed two tips
per volume
and the second question
is there
a need to perform an as found and as
left calibration so a calibration before
maintenance or repair and a calibration
after maintenance and repair
and also here is the iso the new iso
very clear
as the maintenance
or adjustment or repair can affect the
performance of the pipette
a metrological confirmation
should be considered before
and after maintenance adjustment and
repair
so yes
whenever
something is done with the pipette that
can have an effect
on the pipetting result
as found calibration should be performed
as you know
during a calibration the
result can be compared
against a performance specification
three different perform specifications
are common here
first the iso specs that are
in the respective part of the new iso
for example
the specifications for a pipette in part
two
the
second performance specification is the
manufacturer
specification these manufacturer
specifications are usually much smaller
than the iso specs
as these specs are sometimes really very
small
they can not be reached under all
environmental conditions
so when performing a calibration in a
normal lab on the customer's side it
sometimes is not possible
to reach these
specifications
and then last but not least we do have
the performance specifications that are
defined by users
and
these are resulting normally from the
process needs of the customer
and the specific application
the question of course here is now
when following the iso the new iso is it
still possible
to test the pipette against manufacturer
and customer tolerances
or do the cast the calibration
need to be performed always against the
iso tolerances
yeah to fulfill the isis standard the
test against manufacturer and user
tolerances is possible
but
these specifications need to be stricter
or equal to the iso specs
if they are wider
the confirmation of the iso standard
cannot be given
with the last two slides i want to come
back to
the balances
the most important test equipment
when doing a gravimetric test or
calibration of a pipette
here we see some important changes in
the new iso 8655
if we look to the requirements of the
old iso
for example a six-place balance
which means a semi-micro balance was
needed to calibrate a pipette with a
nominal volume of
1 to 10 microliter
with a new iso this changes now if you
look to the second table
with the new iso a sixth place balance
is now needed for pipettes up to a
nominal volume of 20 microliter
which means that the new iso requires
between 11 and 20 microliter a better
balance than the old iso and this is the
same
for example for a nominal volume of 200
microliter
up to now a precision balance with four
places was okay
with the new iso
now analytical balance with five places
is needed here
and one additional important change is
that the new iso
allows
when calibrating a multi-channel pipette
of
20 microliter
on a multi-channel balance
to use here a analytical balance so here
when using a multi-channel balance
not a semi-micro balance is needed
it's okay to use analytical balance and
this of course is very useful
as there are no multi-channel semi-micro
balances in the market yet
regarding the use of
multi-channel
balances there is one
very important sentence in the new iso
multi-channel balance can be used to
measure channels in parallel
and this means the new iso requires
hearing balance
with
several weighing cells that allow such a
parallel measurement
for us this means that systems measuring
multi-channel balances multi-channel
pipettes
sequential
do not match
with the requirements of the new iso
anymore
so here really
a
multi-channel balance is needed that
allows to do this parallel measurement
yeah with this we are at the end of our
short webinar and i like to open now the
q a session
thank you yoni and axel for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question here is for yoni and
this question asks can i use my pipette
with clips from other manufacturers
hi uh yeah
yes
so in the new revision of the standard
the deep manufacturer is always
responsible to ensuring and and
confirming that the combination works
however if a user would like to use any
dead body tips they can do so but i i
highly recommend that they verify that
the compilation works by calibrating the
combination of the tip and the pipette
also this is not a perfect solution as
there is batch debate variants in in
dips as well as in private dude
and if you calibrate the combination
with only one batch of tips and and then
you change the about something down the
line years to come might change
so you cannot be absolutely sure that
the calibration takes account all the
variability in manufacturing so that's
why i would or we would recommend
to only use the combinations that have
been verified by the manufacturers
great thank you
our next question here is for axel this
question asks why are pipettes tested
and calibrated under special conditions
and not in standard laboratory condition
yeah that's the question easy to answer
it's uh yeah because the measurement
results
need to be compared or comparable if you
do a calibration so measurement results
can only be compared
if they are taken always under the same
conditions so uh if you do the testing
in a common laboratory the conditions
fluctuate um
and can
never then be compared to
the measuring results in another lab so
to enable a comparison of results from
different calibration laboratories
the calibration always must be
taken under controlled conditions and
therefore under the same and
special conditions that are given in the
iso
great thank you
another question here for yoni um this
question asks
how often do i have to perform
calibration of my
pipettes yeah
the standard recommends that you at
least annually confirm the metro locator
or performance
and then there is a various different
recommendations from different
manufacturers so
i've seen anything between three to
twelve months to be the recommendation
but what i found on to be the best
practice is to follow the risk page
approach so depending on the risk level
that you have in your application
you might have a very different
calibration requirement or the interval
requirements
if you need to be absolutely sure that
your combination of pilot and deep
delivers
what
like within the limits of the the
devices
then obviously you need to calibrate and
ensure the performance more often and if
your process
has a tolerances for
a little bit more error then obviously
it's not necessary due to alpha
also i would consider liquids that i use
for example volatile liquids they might
damage the internal parts for example
pipettes have seals and and seals
usually are creased
so the volatile liquids might damage
those also some acids might damage the
pipet so in in case i would handle that
kind of liquids i would probably
calibrate the piper more often also i
would include a proper cleaning and
maintenance
in in that case
great thank you yoni
we're getting some great questions from
our audience here and it looks like we
can try to squeeze in a few more
we'll go ahead and proceed with this one
and axel this is directed towards you um
can the number of repetitions in the
tested volumes be changed
uh
yes they can be changed um
if you do a calibration
following the iso
part 7 a2
if you follow
the
test or calibration according to part 6
the repetitions need to be at least 10
so 10 or more is okay but
less than 10 will not work with the iso
part 6 and also not with the iso part 7.
so isopod 6 and 7 requires definitively
10 or more
repetitions less repetitions are only
possible if you do the calibration under
part 7 a2
great
yeah this is this is maybe the same for
the tested volumes also the tested
volumes are fixed if you do the
calibration under
part
seven or part six so uh doing so you
need to do the test
at nominal volume fifty percent of
nominal volume and ten percent
uh if you do a calibration on the part
seven a two also the tested volumes can
be changed
well thank you again yoni and axel for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor sartorius for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you